bury me in satin lay me down on a bed of
roses nyah Rivera's family is speaking
out after her body was discovered at
Lake Piru in California on Monday
following a five-day search a rep for
the family released a statement to ET on
Tuesday remembering their beloved Naya
they lamented quote while we grieve the
loss of our beautiful legend we are
blessed to honor her everlasting legacy
and magnetic spirit Naya was an amazing
talent but was an even greater person
mother daughter and sister I love you
[Music]
the Rivera family thanked fans for their
love and prayers and concluded their
message writing heaven gained our sassy
angel we kindly request that our privacy
be respected during this very difficult
time Kenneth
through the change in glee creators Ryan
Murphy Brad Falchuk and Ian Brennan also
released a statement following the news
of nya's death
revealing that when they cast Naya in
the hit musical show she wasn't a series
regular and only had a few lines in the
pilot but that quickly changed quote it
didn't take more than an episode or two
for us to realize that we had lucked
into finding one of the most talented
special stars we would ever have the
pleasure of working with it's just you
know James true they continued calling
Naya warm and caring and recalled quote
Naya was more than just an actor on our
show she was our friend when you went
for the audition for Glee you were ready
to give up on acting I reached a point
where I was like I have to go to college
and like try to get a real job because
this doesn't seem to be working out and
my mom was the one that was like just
give it six months and go on everything
and don't be picky and just see what
happens
Naya was first reported missing last
Wednesday after she took a boat ride
with her son Josie on Lake Piru in
Ventura County California authorities
say Nia's last moments were likely spent
saving the four-year-olds life there are
a lot of currents on the lake the idea
perhaps being that the boat started
drifting it was unanchored and that she
mustered enough energy to get her son
back onto the boat but not enough to
save herself
[Music]